well hello everybody I thought I'd step
out from behind the camera and say hi my
name is mr. Kobe I'm the maker of
Beverly biology and and more so I wanted
to say thank you I recently passed
10,000 subscribers on my youtube channel
which really is something I never really
envisioned happening you know I started
making this YouTube channel a couple
years ago to help some of my absent
students who might might have missed
some of their class notes or to help
students at home if they thought a topic
was a little more difficult and they
just wanted to do some review I never
really thought that the channel would
grow and and pass 10,000 subscribers so
it's kind of wild to me that it reached
this point but I wanted to say thank you
for for commenting and thank you for
support and thank you for all the kind
words that have been left over the years
and hopefully I can continue to to put
out some more content and and and earn
some more viewership so thank you very
much everybody and I wish you all the
best thank you again